-How are you?
-It's good, Seth.
What's happening?
-I mean, this is incredible.
You know, we talked about this
last time you were here,
but you are now
in the middle of shooting
the 20th season of "SVU."
-Believe it or not.
-20 years!
That's incredible!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I might have
said it before,
but I only came on the show
to do four episodes.
-Yeah.
-And now here we are
in the 20th season.
If we can get
to the next season,
which I'm sure we will,
we'll have the record
for the longest-running
drama in television history.
-It's incredible.
You mentioned -- yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You mentioned you
were only supposed to be on
for four episodes.
You've now been on so long,
your wife, Coco,
has been on three episodes.
Just from being married to you,
she's almost caught up to what
you originally were gonna be.
-Just for hanging out
in the dressing room.
They'll be coming up
with a script, and they'll go,
"Okay, we need a blonde.
She needs big boobs.
Not too big,
kind of like Coco's."
And they go, "Why don't we
just ask Coco, you know?"
And next thing you know,
she's in it,
and so she's got a SAG card,
benefits.
It's worked out.
-Do you support it?
Are you excited when she's
gonna to do an episode?
-I mean, definitely, definitely.
But it's not something
she ever expected.
They just come knock on
the dressing-room door and said,
"Coco,
would you take this role?"
She definitely
rolls with it, yes.
-For people
who are watching at home,
acting is not usually that easy.
-It's not that easy.
They don't usually just show up
and knock on the door
and offer you a part.
-No, it's not that easy, no.
-And one thing that certainly
has not been easy this year is,
you had to be shooting outside
in this weather,
this New York weather, which has
been very intense recently.
-Well, a couple weeks ago,
last week, it was 6 degrees.
And I was shooting outside
with Jennifer Esposito.
She was guest-starring
on the show, and we almost died.
[ Laughter ]
You know, and it's funny,
'cause we talk to people,
they go, "That's fake snow,
and that's fake cold."
I'm like, "What is fake cold?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's difficult,
because your brain goes into,
like, survival mode.
So, your brain is saying,
"Get the hell out of the cold,"
and you're trying
to remember lines.
So there's lots of levels
of acting going on there.
Yeah, but you're really
trying to kill yourself.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, your brain both
kicked in to survival mode
and thought it was a good idea
to film a video
of you guys outside.
-Oh, you saw it?
-Yeah, let's take
a look real quick.
-His face froze.
-Okay.
Me and Jennifer Esposito
are standing out here, freezing.
-Freezing my ass off!
-It's 6 degrees.
People think
that we're in fake cold.
-Not fake cold.
I'm stuffed here,
frigging jacket.
[ Laughter ]
-You also -- yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's real cold right there.
You have
a new member of the family.
You guys got a new dog.
-Yeah, we got a new puppy,
named Princess Alexis.
-Uh-huh.
-And we had Spartacus,
famous Spartacus,
from our reality show.
He passed a couple years ago.
So we had a place missing
in our family.
So, King Maximus now
has a little girlfriend
named Princess Alexis.
-Uh-huh.
-And, yeah, it's crazy now.
She's got little puppy teeth,
so she's biting Chanel
a little bit.
-Here's a picture of all of them
together, your three.
There's Chanel, there's Alexis,
there's Maximus.
-And Chanel's in Alexis' bed.
She is --
Everyone's trying to claim area.
So, Max jumps in one.
And the poor puppy's
just sitting there, like,
"I know I'll find my area
sooner or later."
-Did you know it was a --
Once you had a dog pass away,
did you know eventually
you were gonna get another one?
-Definitely.
-Yeah.
So it was just time.
And we were in California.
And Coco ran into somebody
who had this puppy.
And she comes back
to the hotel room.
I was out there recording,
and she comes back,
and she tells me
this whole story
about how beautiful
the puppy is.
I'm like, "So, where is it?"
Like, I know. And she's all,
"I wanted your approval."
I'm like, "No,
you didn't want my approval.
That puppy is coming.
That pitch you just gave me,
that puppy will be there."
-And it's a good life
to end up with you and Coco.
I mean, lookit.
This is Maximus' birthday.
-Yeah, Max had a little party.
-And I would just say, not all
dogs have birthdays like that.
[ Laughter ]
That's a very --
They're enjoying themselves.
[ Applause ]
I love dogs.
I don't -- I don't trust people
that don't like dogs.
-Yeah, I agree with that.
-Unless you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Unless you can tell me some
traumatic childhood experience
where you got bit or something.
Other than that,
if you just don't like dogs,
you're suspect to me.
I don't trust you.
There's something wrong.
-Yeah.
I think that's fair.
-Dogs are the best.
We don't deserve them.